now Thanksgiving is right around the
corner it's almost here and it's such a
great time of year right a time to hang
out with people you love you you dig way
into too much food you really just kick
back no pressure you don't have to give
gifts or anything I'm very excited about
this holiday season my whole family is
going to be on the turkey float the
first float for the Macy's Thanksgiving
Day Parade
the whole Lopez fam bam we're gonna be
bundled up like that and I'm also going
to be hosting part of NBC's live
coverage of Christmas in Rockefeller
Center on the 30th and to really go next
level I have a brand new movie coming
out on Lifetime this Friday
which I'm really excited about I think
y'all are gonna really like it I get to
combine so many things that I love I'm
dancing and acting there's a little
romance and of course Christmas time so
here's a little sneak peek at stepping
into the holiday
you know maybe this all happened for a
reason when my mom retired I took over
the studio best decision of my life and
now we're creating our own Christmas
show should I add you to the lineup
that's not me anymore
[Music]
at your core you're this guy not that
guy
[Music]
and if that means you are falling for a
woman who doesn't have a publicist
Then Fall
oh
please right there
I get fired from my job I go back home
because my mom's been asking me and I
reconnect with the family and through my
nephew and this uh young lady named Ray
played by Jana Kramer I sort of uh end
up kind of finding love in the Christmas
spirit again you know he goes with a
little dancing romance in between so
hope you all check it out so Kelly
always likes to wrap things up with
something people might be buzzing about
so thought I'd do the same this is what
I'm liking
at the beginning of the show I told you
about my new Lifetime movie debuting on
Friday stepping into the holiday it's
very cool I play a character named Billy
Hernandez AKA Billie Holiday he stars as
a host for a show kind of like Dancing
with the Stars but in the movie he gets
fired replaced by his ex and things take
many turns from there he's got romance
he's got comedy and I love working and
dancing with my co-star Janet Kramer
foreign
[Music]
dialed in now
thank you so much for taking the time to
call in I know this but um would you
mind telling everyone else about your
character in the movie yeah so
um Rey is a dance instructor she used to
tour for Katy Perry and living out of a
suitcase wasn't her thing so she went
home and that's where she found her
maximum Joy by
teaching kids and and being her hometown
nice maximum Joy one of my favorite
expressions from there uh what about
personally what plans do you have for
the holidays other than watching the
movie
I'm definitely gonna watch the movie and
then um you know I'm gonna be honest
with you this year I was I have dreaded
this year more than anything since my
divorce because this was going to be the
year that I didn't have my kids
Christmas morning
um but I've never looked forward to a
day
um more now than ever um I now I'm gonna
get my kids on Christmas Day at noon and
Santa it's actually come the next day so
we're gonna celebrate break Christmas
the next day so I don't miss out on you
know their little feet Pitter pattering
coming down and and seeing the presents
from Santa so I'm excited to create our
own memory this year and I'm really
looking forward to that oh that's
awesome
I'm so glad that worked out right there
thank you so much Jana I'm liking your
posts right now
seven of the holiday premieres this
Friday night on Lifetime hope you check
it out and enjoy all right now we've hit
the point where Kelly usually gives the
guest a thousand dollars courtesy of the
show season long partner pilot pin
makers of G2 the go-to pen of the Kelly
Clarkson show but I think it'd be uh
it'd show way too much favoritism if I
give it to Janna right so today the
money is going to someone in the
audience
so if everyone could please get up real
quick and look under their chairs
because someone has a check taped under
their chair and it's going to come up
with a thousand bucks
congratulations what's your name Kaylee
hi Kaylee congrats
[Applause]
what do you uh what do you plan to do
with the money I'm going to Bahrain next
year I'm gonna travel with my husband
there you go
yeah spend it on the vacation good for
you congrats and happy holidays to you
nice
and a big thanks
to all our guests this hour Jonathan
Majors Casino Jackson who won the last
show Angelica Ortega the Pierce 14th
choir Natalie Pascarella and all our
friends over at NBC4 New York
alicaster and Lawrence zaryanus Kelly
says have a great day and if it's not
change it
[Music]
thank you foreign
[Applause]
[Music]